لرفع هذا العالم احتفالا بالانتصار احتاج
الامر تدمير باخمه عن بكره ابيها وازهاق
ارواح من عشرين الى ثلاثين الف جندي روسي
وفق معطيات غربيه
ومثلهم من الاوكرانيين وفق معطيات روسيه
القوات الروسيه تحتفل بالانتصار والقوات
الاوكرانيه تنفي
تصريحات ليست صحيحه كما هي الحال دائما
وحداتنا هناك تسيطر على مبنيين ولديها
منشات محصنه في الجزء الجنوبي الغربي من
ضخمه
يجمع الخبراء ان لا اهميه استراتيجيه
لباخموت كان عدد سكانها 70 الفا فيها
مناجم ملح ومصنع نبيذ قديم
القتال في باخم تحول من عسكري الى سياسي
الكرملين بحاجه الى نصر معنوي بعد فشل
القوات في السيطره على اي مدينه منذ الصيف
الماضي
سمعه قوات فاجنر في قدرتها القتاليه على
المحك ورئيسها
يقاتل من اجل الحفاظ على نفوذه في موسكو
استمرت عمليه الاستيلاء على ضخمه مفرمه
اللحم كما يطلق عليها
224 يوما وبدات في الثامن من اكتوبر العام
الماضي لمنح الجيش الروسي المنهك فرصه
للتعافر ولم يكن هناك سوى شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الخاصه لم تكن هناك قوات رسميه
محموله جوا كما زعم المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه او اي شخص اخر لقد ساعدنا
انفسنا بانفسنا
في اوكرانيا اطلقوا على باخ مطلق بحصن
المعنويات استخدمت المدينه لاضعاف الجيش
الروسي وقتل اكبر قدر ممكن من الجنود
وعرقله التقدم نحو مناطق حضريه اكبر مثل
سلوفيانس وكراماتورز وهي مدن محصنه وسيكون
تقدم الروسي نحوها اكثر دمويه من ضخم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات